[Music]  this mission is a simple in and out  agent valerian he'll be running solo I  only work with my partner hi we're a  team  you're running nearly 20 minutes late  yeah well time flies when you're having  fun  [Music]  welcome to alpha  [Music]  the city of a thousand planets where for  hundreds of years every species has  shared their knowledge and their  intelligence with each other it's  paradise  in his life  after centuries of peace and prosperity  an unknown force wants to destroy all we  have created agents valerian and Laura  lein you have less than 10 hours to find  the threat and eliminate it back  phone universe is after us  we need the two of you to be the  guardians of our future  you sure you know you do it  valerian trust me  come on one  your destiny is in your hands  I taught him how to do that  is blue it makes me  because